good day everyone and welcome I'm Jack
Van Horn from the University of Virginia
and I am very proud to welcome you to
this edition of our 2022 2023
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar Series this lecture series is
supported by uva's integrated
translational Health Institute of
Virginia the UVA brain Institute the
College of Arts and Sciences the school
of data science and through grants from
the National Institutes of General
Medical Sciences since 2016 the
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar Series has been focusing on the
use of data science methodologies
artificial intelligence deep learning
and statistical modeling as they pertain
to differing themes in the biomedical
and Health Sciences this year's theme is
data science and the public health
consequences of the covid-19 pandemic
where each Friday we enjoy presentations
from leading thinkers about the issues
the promises the opportunities and the
hurdles associated with understanding
the secondary health effects of covet
19. these include delayed Health
checkups delayed treatments Mental
Health
drug abuse increased obesity and the
long lingering health effects associated
with the SARS covid-19 virus
participants selected for our biomedical
data science Innovation lab program will
leverage these presentations as vital
material in our culminating in-person
Grant project development Workshop to be
held at the lodge at St Edwards Park in
Seattle Washington in June of 2023.
today I am delighted to welcome our
speaker Dr Mike fumilari Senior research
manager and head of the Epi team at The
Institute for disease model which is an
Institute within within Global Health at
the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation
Mike is a core discipline is using
mathematical modeling to study
infectious disease transmission and to
improve the utility of disease
surveillance data since joining IDM in
2012 he has been working closely with
Partners in the global polio eradication
initiative to assess the impacts of
polio vaccination policies he is also a
co-founding principal investigator of
the Seattle flu study and Innovative
collaborative and in-home
multi-pathogens self-testing that
identified the first case of community
transmission of covid-19 in the United
States in 2020 and 2021 he co-led idm's
covid-19 response with a focus on
analytics and modeling to inform code 19
control strategies in collaboration with
the Washington State Department of
Health and with Governor Inslee in
Washington state his current teams and
personal research
are focused mostly on pathogen
environmental surveillance phylogenic
and in inference methods evolutionary
epidemiology of the polio virus and
immunological modeling and transmission
in epidemiology in continuing with the
2022-2023 biomedical data science
seminar series theme Mike's lecture
today is entitled choices give meaning
to uncertainty stories from pandemic
emergence policy advising and a very
personalized medicine in his talk Mike
is going to discuss these issues in the
context of his work on pandemic
emergence policy advising and as a
person living with multiple sclerosis
forced to navigate the trade-offs in
covet prevention and Ms care as always
we are streaming this lecture live and
for recording via YouTube and if you are
watching on YouTube thank you for
joining us also our specially selected
2022-2023 biomedical data science
Innovation lab participants and alumni
are encouraged to submit any questions
they have for Mike via the chat feature
in their Zoom sessions I'll synthesize
these questions and ask them on your
behalf during the last 10 minutes or so
of the lecture and with that welcome
Mike we are really excited to hear about
your work your progress and your
personal story thank you Mike
thank you um thank you for that
excellent introduction
um yeah so before diving in I just want
to tell you a little bit about our
Research Institute because we're
somewhat unique in the global Health
landscape so I'm in a place called The
Institute for disease modeling which as
of the summer of 2020 is a research
institute within the bill and Linda
Gates Foundation uh prior to that we
were in a global good uh philanthropic
investment fund over at intellectual
Ventures um and when the covet pandemic
started I wasn't yet in the Gates
Foundation but I was still at IBM
um our mission is to shape Global
efforts to eradicate infectious disease
and to achieve permanent improvements in
health for those most in need
um it's a multi-disciplinary team of
about 90 people we have a core of
research scientists software Engineers
there's technical writing project
management admin I.T you know the whole
um body of work to for technical work
together
um as I mentioned we're now an embedded
Research Institute within bmgf we
support researchers and policy makers in
global health and part of our mission is
to develop computational tools to
support that while we're part of the
bill Melinda Gates Foundation Institute
for disease modeling is not a funder we
are a research partner you can think of
this as intramural research
um we work with a wide ecosystem of
Partners it's universities other ngos
government Ministries research Public
Health institutions and partner with the
grant making divisions of bmgf in
certain ways
um also just to call out for those of
you who have postdocs or students
looking to graduate we are just now
opening a few new roles in mathematical
modeling the first one in environment in
enteric disease modeling is up as of a
week ago over the next month or two or
three there'll probably be three ish
more so yeah keep an eye out on that and
let us know if you're interested
um because I'm bad at doing
acknowledgments at the end because the
momentum carries me away I wanted to
highlight a small selection of people
that were very close to some of the
stories we'll talk about today
um on the left are colleagues from
Mostly Institute for disease modeling
and Bill Linda Gates Foundation
um and on the right are many of our
external Partners both in government
um and and in academic research um you
know some folks you might have heard of
like Trevor Bedford Governor Inslee
um but also you know many other folks as
well
um you know I'm gonna tell stories today
from a fairly personal perspective in
the context of science because I I one
is I I want to share that part of the
process and how the doing of science is
affected by how I how I think about the
doing of Science and you know for folks
that are trying to develop their careers
right now and pick their Direction I
want to you know model something that I
don't see talked about enough and that I
value
um here and so but whenever I say I I'm
almost always with talking about a weed
um so yeah so with that in mind what's
this talk about
um the teaser from Gianna was a lectures
could be on any topic you prefer that's
related to the secondary consequences of
covid-19 pandemic or the data science's
challenges associated with it
um as I mentioned I've taken that to
sort of as an opportunity to give a talk
that balances uh some technical material
and what did we do as modelers
um with some of the personal aspects of
doing that work
um you know as in the framing
um the title right really what I want
this talk is about is uncertainty right
that is the the story of the pandemic
especially early on
um thinking clearly through uncertainty
uh that's a that's a skill this series
there's principles um there's ways of
going about it
um importantly decision making under
uncertainty because that was the key
challenge or one of the key challenges
of the pandemic along the way I'm going
to be open about some challenges that I
think we collectively face as
individuals that I also personally have
faced and you know I'm going to be a bit
normative about what I think are our
responsibilities of scientists um in a
way that is probably not quite becoming
out of of a person of my age but for
which I feel very strongly and want to
use this opportunity
um I hope you know the mindset I'm
hoping you can be in is one enjoy some
stories I'm not going to be terribly
detailed technically at least in the way
my brain works
um I hope you can enjoy that um also
throughout covid throughout everything
we have people who pose as experts um I
am going to pose as a very confident
expert
um at times I you should be evaluating
my credibility
um and also thinking about what that
would be like as a colleague and I hope
then some of the reflectiveness of this
talk helps you reflect on your work in
relation to society
um in relation to the program that
you're in
um so okay more specifically right
um I want to try to put you in my shoes
during three critical periods during the
pandemic
um first starting in January you know
figuring out the Dynamics and
epidemiology of what was then 2019 out
of gold
um from there a little bit on the what I
think I came to understand was our work
in in the interaction between science
and public and government of building a
shared mental model
um that being a point that I'll come
back to a very important
um and last I take this opportunity to
say something that I don't think we talk
about enough um I had a unique
perspective on personalized medicine as
an immunocompromised person
um I have multiple sclerosis I was
diagnosed back in grad school I kept it
to myself uh professionally until the
March 1st of 2020 when I decided to tell
my bosses because I did not know what my
life was going to be like during a
pandemic
um and have since felt that you know
what people like me got to talk um and
so there's some interesting science in
this um and I wanted to share the
interesting science part of that um
where I have the the unique Fortune of
having been both an expert in covid-19
and a person having to navigate their
own care for a complex disease
um I hope this takes away some
Illustrated general principles
um and again I hope it prompts
reflection
um and to be clear I'm expressing my own
opinions from my own experience uh
nothing I'll say today is an official
position of the bill Monday Gates
Foundation
right so it's January 2020 and you read
the news strange pneumonia out of Wuhan
right so this is the situation I want
you to sort of put your imagination into
um you know you like me you want to know
what's happening and what's going to
happen right why first foremost you know
we're compelled as scientists something
uh you appears to be unique serious and
real is happening in our domain of
expertise
um and that is you know of of deep
motivation
um just intrinsically for me
um and in my case also my work is
related I was working in pandemic
preparedness before this happened I was
co-pi of uh what at the time was the
largest respiratory surveillance study
in the country uh with the Seattle flu
study we had started in uh 2018 to
develop uh a integrated testing data
analysis multi-pathogen surveillance
platform in the Seattle metro area
coupled with hospitals and you know at
home testing where you got a swab sent
to your house and a courier brought it
back in a day and a half later you had a
result if you were positive for
something all that started in November
of 2018.
um and so we were trying we were trying
to demonstrate what could you do with
the infrastructure available in the
United States
if you had the funding of a Bill Gates
to support where the funding wasn't the
problem but all the problems were going
to be how do you wire that up in this
environment
um you know so that was of course
professional interest
so but beyond that though for all of us
you know things I want to highlight is
like an important question is like
there's something compelling happen but
like
are we capable of helping and I honestly
think that's a question that I'm not
nearly enough people ask themselves
um as well you know as we see later you
know do you have relevant research
program right you have the expertise
um something else that I thought was
really important and I saw lots of
different behavior
um do you want to help any way you can
when something like this happens
including me in the other metaphorical
equivalent of filling sandbags like
maybe you don't get to be the expert
right now but there's something you can
do you're good at plumbing and data
science or you're willing to write a
report even though you wish you were
giving the TV talk whatever like you
know did you is that where you were okay
with entering that's a choice
alternatively like you have a thing you
love to do you have a thing you're
really good at you know do you want to
find your niche in this now disrupted
ecosystem that's also a very valid
Choice
um people made that choice well
um but it's a different way of
Engagement when you have different
expectations for what you're going to be
involved with
um as I mentioned before you know you
got to do the work
um pontificating because you read some
abstracts is not good enough
um are you going to do the grunt work of
knowing the thing um before opening your
mouth
um related living with scientific
discomfort
um living with the risk of being wrong
I'll just say for me that was a huge
change I The Institute for disease
modeling we often partner in you know in
a relatively Silent Way in the past um
would work with I would have a small
role with a couple who committees that
serve the global poly eradication
program and you know write a handful of
papers and mostly internal PowerPoints
that go into decision making meetings
and you know quite invisible
um but all of a sudden finding yourself
in the position to have to speak in a
very public way
um was a huge transition emotionally
um of course also important is can you
pay for it you want to Pivot can we pay
for it uh the question I think to ask as
you're building a career now is you know
how do you position yourself so that
that's easier if you want to do this
kind of work
um I was fortunate to have a very
flexible funding model in my Institute
we have hard salaries we're not closely
tied to Grants
um so I trusted to Pivot based on my
judgment uh not everyone has that
privilege
um other labs their work was closer to
this they were able to Pivot and there
were other gloves that pivoted even
though they couldn't pay for it
um hope the best would happen and some
that you know people I know personally
that could have done very good work that
could not support their lab if they made
a significant pivot and had to accept
that
um and the last point that I don't think
enough people talked about is you know
why you why are you really doing this
um you know it's you know you want to
help or you're just afraid of missing
out and you want to have a stage
um so you know from that big picture I
want to give you a feel of what it was
actually like
um in the English speaking World
starting right around January 1st 2020.
um you know
but yeah I will I think on like the
Saturday after New Year's after New
Year's I opened up my Feedly and read
some of the flu blog community and you
know saw a strange pneumonia in Wuhan
and was like you know came back to work
on a Monday and kept reading and by the
middle of that first week of January it
was like uh
um there's something there's something
happening
um very quickly other people did this
and there was this remarkable thing that
I have not seen the story told very well
from this early
um where a small but dedicated group of
volunteers created data out of news
um they created analyzable data out of
social media posts
um you know and there were these
lineless efforts there was probably I
think three or four of them one of which
turned into Johns Hopkins effort
um another you know also inspired the um
U.S covet tracking project that came out
of the Atlantic but you know people were
taking either they were Native Mandarin
readers or using Google translate taking
official you know reports from official
social media mouthpieces on mostly on
weibo of case reports that were often
quite detailed in the beginning
um putting that into open Google
spreadsheets that I had a bunch of
information symptom onset
hospitalization was there a known
exposure you know Travelers that had
been to Wuhan and left had an exposure
window that you could actually use to
help understand the infection
progression
um this was an enormously useful
resource
um you know an enorm and this was
example of something that people just
did
um it filled a massive hole in global
Public Health infrastructure
um and enabled people like me sitting in
the comfort of my home in the Seattle
area to start not just reading what was
happening but start engaging with it as
a scientist engaging with it
specifically as a mathematical modeler
of infectious disease we had a whole
bunch of things he wanted to know about
this disease and and just a quote from I
think early February that I got
permission share for my memory of a
colleague of mine davidpiggett at UW
um you know once the case numbers were
bigger this was now International the
effort that he was part of you know he
goes I spent last night watching shit's
creek and adding 10 000 cases to the
line list like that was what that became
um and why this is so important is it
enabled people like myself to know to
learn about the disease very quickly and
in fact often honestly a week before
leaving the fastest papers came out
um so I'm showing here just a whiteboard
figure from January 29th of 2020.
um you can see my sort of portly frame
shadowed in the middle of it I took a
picture after this meeting
um where I sketched out our best guess
on what was the entire acute disease
course of of covet 19.
um that was mostly informed by the line
list and a couple of papers that had
come out you know we knew things like
that the latent period before you would
start shedding virus was you know two to
five days
um you shed probably for seven to twenty
one more you were infectiousness for a
big peak of that was stuff that we could
guess from either exposure data or
knowing other viruses
um in analogy with other viruses we
could guess the shape of what the viral
titer must have looked like before there
was not a single measurement
um just under the assumption oh wait
this is probably working like a
transmission like a flu virus just
longer
um oh it's not looking like SARS one
which had a different shape because
we're seeing evidence of transmission
from people who are not very sick
um mapping that onto the symptomatic
course in the bottom the blue incubation
period um the acute symptomatic versus
severe one of the things that was really
obvious reading the case reports
yourself was when people talked about
symptomatic you know coveted back then
they were talking about two things and
you could see it there was they were
talking about you got a fever
um cough and then they're also talking
about you're about to die and you went
to the hospital
um and so from that you could parse that
you know that two that four to fourteen
days estimate was often clouding two
different things and parsing it apart
helped you understand the progression
um also importantly and I've drawn on
this figure is the transition from
incubation of symptoms to acute symptoms
with the first Blue Bar I've drawn about
a day after what I thought was the rapid
rise in viral titer
um that was a guess because by January
it was all pretty clear that there was
pre or asymptomatic transmission from a
handful of case reports there was a
reports of a restaurant in Wuhan there
were a couple of Japanese tour bus
drivers who got sick from you know
people on the bus
um despite being you know behind a glass
partition
um
and so this was known um and I want you
to reflect on what came later
um so many people who did not know
because they did not do the work early
enough and in March they were talking
about stuff that they didn't know
um from the line list uh we you know
could also understand a lot of case
fatality even just from the early cases
um this is showing data from I don't
know this is probably if I remember
correctly like a hundred and maybe 100
cases the first from January 15th and
earlier
um already clear was the age gradient in
severity
um you know already clear was you had to
deal with strong right censoring as you
were watching the outcomes
um you know it took three weeks from
when you first got infected on average
to when people died
um and you needed to account for that to
understand the severity
um and I will say that yeah this is when
we started doing work in public at least
through GitHub
um realizing that it didn't if you
didn't write it down and put it
somewhere um it didn't exist and it
mattered that it was somewhere for some
people can read it
um you know other things that I want to
highlight are how do we learn about
incidents you know there was not a
prevalence there was not a lot of
testing most testing was based on X-rays
of lung symptoms was very incomplete
beta
um but people are doing really
interesting stuff with opportunistic
sampling um there were no a handful of
papers this is a grab from one of you
know in the case of international travel
we saw the Wuhan repatriation flights
um these are after the Wuhan uh lockdown
started you know was starting on January
23rd
um people you know governments were
flying out their citizens um and then
testing uh people who on those planes
and from those planes we got prevalence
estimates of approximately one percent
um those were consistent with other
estimates that had been done
um from domestic travel within China um
by a group from Hong Kong University
that was the first to publish on this
um and so we started to get a picture of
like what at the end of January there
was one-ish percent prevalence and so
with 100 prevalence and an understanding
of the exponential growth we could work
our way backwards
um
other things that are interesting you
know this was work from the mobs lab
Alex vespiani and so on and I'm showing
a snapshot but there was once a website
that was updating this every day I'm
just again looking at the Flight Network
and coloring by was a case detected
um something we were able to see here is
that the cases were showing up pretty
much in proportion to how many flights
were leaving China
um and you could watch the cases
accumulate and land be found first in
the countries with the most travel
um and so again you got a picture of of
um what was happening what's really
interesting about this is these Flight
Network modeling approaches
they're often terrible like
quantitatively they're often poorly
predictive um the Ebola outbreak had a
number of massive Prat Falls by people
assuming well-mixed modeling
um that had no validity because Ebola is
a highly socially contact driven disease
you know close contact with acutely ill
people and they're they're on you know
their their
um and funerals
um but seeing the simplest models you
know the front of the epidemiological
modeling textbook work over and over
again for measurements out of Wuhan was
the kind of thing that we often don't
think about how to model but it's
actually really important
um if the simplest well-mixing models
are working well that tells you the
virus is at this point in the epidemic
early on
doesn't care a lot about social
structure
um it's not entrenched in specific
behavioral patterns
um it's kind of confined just about
anybody
um and that means that the transmission
must be easy for the virus right again
it's not SARS one it's not Ebola it also
must be hard for people to see right
they must not it must not just be
acutely ill people because acute people
are not getting on planes very at high
frequency in proportion to normal travel
patterns
um so seeing this population Randomness
work around the world also gave us a lot
of picture about a a disease that could
easily transmit for which people you
know were not acutely aware that they
were infecting other people and that was
clear as the most likely thing before
even the first unambiguous reports of of
asymptomatic transmission that came out
you know a week after what I'm talking
about here was available
um
and so working backwards with prevalence
and and case fatality
um understanding of the disease course
the delays you know three groups of us
uh independently myself one of them were
able to produce the first credible
estimates of the infection fatality rate
um it came out between like point three
and one percent for China
um interesting thing about that point
three is the lowest end number was mine
and I actually had an arithmetic mistake
that Neil Ferguson caught and we updated
it it was closer to one percent but I am
telling you what was reported as of
exactly the day that this report from
who was made
um
that your but the age structure we
already were able to think through
things like regardless if infection goes
unchecked Italy the second oldest
country on Earth was going to have a
hard time
um Japan first oldest country on Earth
would have had a hard time except for
they were very good on infection control
from very early on in contrast a lot of
the conversation about is there covet in
sub-Saharan Africa what does that look
like
um severe disease fundamentally
important but early on there was like oh
the all sorts of weird stuff like people
don't get it here but it was like we
knew they would have a lower mortality
rate it's much younger age pyramid and
that was all clear from the Chinese data
that held up since
and so I just want to leave you for a
moment with this
um this was a figure I prepared um this
is the February 19th version
um it takes the cdc's flu pandemic
ranking system that they had published I
think right after like in 2010 and draws
what we expect for kova 19 on it
um this is based on infection fatality
rate it's based on the transmissibility
um
and I think why I wanted to share this
is because we all know what came after
um
we knew what this was going to be any
person in March 2020 or later who talked
of uncertainty about the fatality rate
who talked enormous uncertainty about
how many people would get infected if we
do nothing maybe it'll just go away
modelers who put out models where things
peaked in April and deterministically
disappeared in June
um all of that was incompatible with
what was known and published by February
of 2020. so every platform person who
was talking with less confidence than I
am right now was under informed
and as a field and as a discipline
that's something I still think about
yeah so I kind of want to have an
interlude here on this sort of thinking
about what's going on behind this cloud
of stuff right you know
I often think about systems thinking and
I've cribbed these points from the intro
to systems thinking report from the UK
government Science office
um systems thinking is a way of
exploring and develop effective action
by looking at Connected holes rather
than separate parts you're looking back
on that theme of the slides I just
showed you those were each pieces of uh
many variables that go on understanding
a disease that work together to
understand the whole
almost nothing I talked about was a
representative sample of anything
um most of it barely qualified as a data
set in a traditional sense but there was
an enormous amount of evidence and that
evidence through mathematical thinking
about how do infectious disease systems
interact
could allow you to get an accurate
picture and again the the citations hold
up this isn't retrospective we have we
have the evidence not just me the other
people who had done this in parallel
people like me around the world the
evidence exists I know you could get it
right in the first time that requires
thinking about context and beliefs right
it's how do people think of the system
because you're going to interact with
people
um what when you say the system how do
you define it with respect to everything
else in the universe
um you know it's not a it's not just
this aspect of disease it's not just a
clinical lens there's there's Parts
clinical lenses apart there's the holes
the whole thing there's layers of
different scales of Parts everything is
connected everything has feedback loops
and on all those connections Parts holes
layers there are processes dynamical
processes that propagate uh what happens
whether it be information infection
Etc through that system
um
our research programs are often strongly
incentivized to do some part of a system
you become a narrow expert in a deep way
um your your account you're it's you're
good at writing grants to be able to say
like I'm the person who does this I know
how to do this we have all the lab
equipment to do this
um very valuable work and that kind of
valuable work feeds the system thinking
but I do think in an emergency situation
and I do know that other talks that's
watched in the series have brought this
up before
you do need systems thinkers in key
places
um and I think as Leaders
um in the future and think about our
careers think about are do we want to
position ourselves as system thinkers if
if so what do we need to do to be
actually good at it not just to be a
thinker you know be like and I actually
have the skills conversely if we know
that we're not going to position
ourselves that way because our passion
is you know in my case in an alternate
life it's the evolutionary virology of
polio viruses you know if I went to if I
left Global health and went to Academia
I would write weird evolutionary bio
papers on a nearly extinct virus because
I love it
um okay that's great do that um I'm
asking you at this point you know as you
think about shaping your career relative
to the incentives to to do one type of
thing
um how do you want to relate to the
systems around you
okay
so switching topics for you know or
continuing on the story you know I pose
a provocative question that we did not
answer and I'll tell you how we didn't
answer it but it's March 2020 should
Seattle area close schools right so my
study Seattle flu study
um we in early February we had uh worked
with Thermo Fisher um this was not me in
some ways I was the least important of
the 11-ish principal investigators
um on the story
um but um I worked with Thermo Fisher to
design a sars2s day that we could add on
our
um you know Multiplex respiratory
disease array but of course as everyone
I think maybe remembers
um no one was allowed to use tests that
weren't developed by CDC at that time so
we sat on it for a few weeks and
um by late February the third week of
February we're fully aware of how
untenable this was there were cases
popping up all over the world There Was
You Know transmission was starting to
happen you know we're seeing massive
outbreaks in Italy
and so we made a decision to start using
our test
um despite it not having been approved
um I think you know the thing that I
think cut through the fear
um was Michael book
um who's a professor a researcher at the
Fred Hutch Cancer Research Institute
just sort of asking like you know what
would a reasonable person think
um if you know we had the information
and that was the clarifying thing and so
with that we found the first evidence of
community Transmission in Washington
state and I think contemporaneous the
second you know parallel to a community
transmission identified in California
um there was a you know a student that
was about to go back to high school um
and got the phone call at six in the
morning and and that was that
um
now at this point in time you know we
know we have Community transmission you
know literally miles from my house and
my organization Institute for disease
modeling we started to Pivot really
aggressively to the
to try to understand this disease as an
Institute and build software tools that
were better than we had to do
um you know all sorts of different kinds
of modeling to help understand the
situation and help understand what
happened I show here that you know sort
of the most prude useful thing we did
um as a model this was our first
mathematical model of the Seattle area
um it was published this is a report we
published on March 10th
um
it was calibrated to the very little bit
of mortality and case data that we had
consistent with what we knew about the
disease from Mostly out of China
um and we were only able to simulate
random mixing we did not have social
structure built into the model that
looked like Seattle at this point in
time we were not able to model schools
in a meaningful way
um but we we realized that like this
whole thing this whole game right now is
about decision making collectively in
society you know
Wuhan and China had shown us that you
could use physical distancing to reverse
the tide
um and so we knew that that was a choice
that could be made and so we made a
choice in the rest of our work on
situational awareness in in all the
contexts where we were the ones saying
here's what we think is happening here's
what we think could happen we never
showed a forecast we always showed
scenarios with choices because we knew
we were trying to we were talking to
people to say here's what can happen in
in your control I think that's one of
the things that was really important
um in understanding of covid and
especially in the beginning is it was in
our control and to be honest it still is
in our control and I have heartbreak
about that I won't talk about today
um imagine our surprise when the day
after we see this figure on TV uh behind
the governor I'd never met uh Governor
rinsley at this point in time we had no
relationship with the Department of
Health we were just doing this on spec
for it helped us learn and we thought it
would be helpful and we were sharing it
with our local contacts in King County
the Seattle area
um immediately after that uh Public
Health officials asked us about their
work about the work we had a big phone
meeting with a hundred people who knew a
hell of a lot more about public health
in the United States than I ever did
um very stressful this was a um you have
very new and they asked what did the
modeling say and we were like what we
could find is if you know if we can cut
at least 75 percent of the transmission
links you'll see prevalence turn around
um
you know we had framed it in the context
of one point in terms of like school
closures as an option we did model
school closures but we all we were able
to say is we don't know exactly how much
something like that would do
um we just know that they would be very
disruptive across Society because of the
way contact patterns work
um we also knew the businesses large
businesses like Microsoft and and
um Amazon and Boeing had already started
uh to telling workers to stay home
um and we sort of said we don't know how
to tell you what to do but we know that
if you can figure out how to accomplish
this things will go back
um
government schools businesses
individuals in the public they may you
know shortly after this they made the
decision to close the schools and
transmission as much work
um to home as possible we were this you
know by March 6 by March 11th March 12th
this was already well underway
um by March 23rd there was a Statewide
policy
um we were a week you know ahead of
almost everyone
um California was also at the front of
the line
um and probably saved a few thousand
washingtonians just this
um
something really exciting that started
to happen afterwards was by putting the
work out in public
um and then government choosing to put
the work out in public even further
um it started this process that I I
don't know how to prove
um its value but I believe was really
fundamental to some of what went well
here
um was we started people started using
our work as a small piece of their
information environment to build their
mental model of what was happening
um this was a blog post from somebody I
never met who starts off with you know
there's a plot that's been stuck in my
brain for about 10 days and this is on
March 25th which was our plot and he
goes I'm going to take the data that the
Department of Health is putting out and
put it on the plot and and see if I can
figure out what what uh what reduction
in Social distancing have we occur have
we accomplished and you came to a
reasonable conclusion it looked like we
were following the 25 reduction curve at
that point in time
um things were still going up well but
they hadn't not going up quite as fast
um this was just one person you know in
a small way building their own picture
with the input of us as scientists
um that happened all over the newspapers
worked um with government with us and
did a lot of really good science to say
what the science communication to say
this is what people think is happening
again our model is what I'm highlighting
but there were versions of this from the
public health officials from other
research groups from direct from
government
um you know continuing to communicate in
our communities in our state as it grew
this is what we think is happening
um it wasn't here's what I it wasn't
always here's what I think you should do
that was governor inslee's job here's
what we're going to do
um but it was often just what is
happening it was situational awareness
over and over again
um you know seeing it by March you know
or by the second week you know third
week of March that things hadn't turned
around yet a stronger stay home order
was issued and that bent the peak in
western Washington
um and again and this is our model based
estimates of prevalence
um and we probably never hit one percent
prevalence which was to say what Wuhan
hit that I was talking about
um you know two months earlier
um and our modeling I think was a small
piece of that and
um yeah and so I just want to highlight
the roles right in this because this
first month which we were learning as we
go building on a career in public health
engagement and Global Health engagement
around the world but never at this pace
and never at this level of of
stakeholder visibility you know media
government public you know there was the
scale of it was totally new
um you know we recognized that we needed
our team collectively to stay up to date
on the Sciences as much as possible on
having a team at one point was part-time
30 people around 10 people every day was
a huge part of that
um that we were incorporating in the
models you know mental models at the top
scale how does the world work in a way
that I can engage with that you can
engage with but then also computational
because the computational models put the
discipline in the mental model you can't
have one without the other
um computational models that aren't
serving some broader understanding are
just you know they're playing with
computer conversely
trying to build a mental model that
doesn't have any mathematical rubber
meets the road pressure is how you get
opinions that are not that don't make
sense mechanistically or how you start
how you continue to believe something
it's no longer possibly true if you've
been engaging with the data
um we were trying to serve ourselves as
scientists you know my institute's focus
is global Health not domestic health and
so we ended up because you know this was
an emergency and all hands on deck we
ended up doing a lot of work locally but
that was always in part to serve
understanding how we could help people
globally in places where the data were
not so rich and the relationship's not
so strong
um
part of it was we all you know we always
shared uncertainty and tried to talk
about what that meant
um we always enumerated multiple options
for the future as I said because we're
always emphasizing it was a choice
nothing was predestined nothing was
guaranteed to occur you got to pick your
adventure
um and you know we would carefully
express our opinions whether when we
were requested or when it was part of an
ongoing relationship but we tried hard
to not push for personal preferences
um another thing that's really important
is it was really clear with our partners
and the way we talked in to everybody
that we interacted with researchers
media government our families we're
learning together as we go there was no
false certainty there was no this is how
it works there was no you know it was
here's what we understand today and
again making everything as public as
possible and I've listed a lot of our
roles
but actually our partner's roles are in
some sense much larger and and simpler
to list we were a piece of input we were
part of a relationship Network I don't
even know how many other inputs went
into how many other people I don't know
you know when we when we worked with
Governor inslee's office over the next
18 months I have no idea the the many
other organizations which ones had what
Leverage What what meetings had what you
know we were just like here's what we
think is going on scientifically let's
keep the front edge alive
they take that they take what they value
whether it be someone reading the
newspaper someone reading our report or
Twitter
um someone making decisions for eight
million people whatever they else they
value whatever other inputs they get and
they are the ones who have the decision
to act
um they are the ones who act as they see
fit um it's our place to help inform
it's our place to honestly communicate
when asked what we think we would do
um but we have to trust that we don't
know we can't model everything
um I don't know if I'm right about
everything and there are lots of choices
where I think I would have probably made
them differently where the outcome was
better than what I would have made
um and so it was really really good to
know
and so I just want to leave again I I'm
taking way too much credit because I'm
just talking about my story
um but despite having the first outbreak
in the country
um Washington State today was 46 per
capita in total deaths
um in the United States and so not only
did things go right at the beginning but
a lot of things stayed right
um relative to other places
um they could have gone more right
um but a lot of things went okay and I
think that the shared mental model
um part that happened a tiny way that we
contributed and just the ecosystem here
built I think was a big part of it
um
yeah and so this is something again this
is you know data science and analytics
um
you know I I really have been come to
understand that this is the point this
is the point of being a mathematical
modeler is to help people build mental
models help myself do that
um right computational modeling is
essential for disciplining those models
it's essential for making them specific
mechanistic for learning how the system
actually works right you have to the
computational model is incredibly
valuable there but it's it's niche just
specifically that
um we have to understand there's a small
domain of things we can ever model
um computationally explicitly and those
are going to interface with things that
we don't have the expertise for or we
cannot quantify and understanding how to
make the handoff from those interfaces
is a is an act of learning that one has
to engage in deliberately if they want
to be good at this
um and again good modeling is useful if
it helps people make better decisions
right it's not about a paper it's not
about cool code
um a lot of the modeling we did was way
simpler mathematically than we thought
it was going to be
um there was different or there were
different kinds of innovations that
weren't like the machismo of simulating
a million people and doing complex
interactions but we're like you know
turning
um you know doing inference of our
effective into a deterministic algorithm
instead of the stochastic one so you
could run it in the millisecond do it
every day
um but most of the the actual Concepts
were quite simple because that's what
people needed turned out you know
um and knowing you can't do everything
so you have to hand it off to others and
you have to approach others with the
expectation that you're going to only
give them what you're going to give them
and they're going to run with it you
have to trust that
um
you know is how I think about the work
that that we did and I think about it
going forward how we will continue to do
it to the one of my best of my abilities
all right
so there's one more theme
um kind of build a very different scale
of the system
um I wanted to talk to this audience
about my personal experience as somebody
living with multiple sclerosis during uh
this pandemic
um
you know March 15 2020 I have a picture
I took of myself
um this was a point in time where we
were being told masks are either not
effective or if you have them we have to
save the n95s for the healthcare workers
and I was some maybe one percent of my
grocery store at this point in time was
wearing a mask and I felt um I had to
explain myself because it was such a
socially
um disruptive feeling
um and so yeah there's me with an immuno
compromise on my shirt so I can go to
Trader Joe's and feel like I'm not going
to get harassed
um
moving forward
um you know I a very scientifically
interesting problem that also is
personally very relevant I think the two
together means I probably overthought
the hell out of this and you will enjoy
possibly thinking about that
um so the treatment that I use for
multiple sclerosis the one of the more
effective ones or more effective
families are are B cell depleting
therapies they they eradicate most of
your B cells which are the antibody
producing cells
um and that reduces the um progression
of Ms because Ms is mediated we now know
by Epstein-Barr virus which as an aside
Ms is long Epstein-Barr
um so something to think about a chronic
disease arising from viral infection
um
but regardless of you know compromise
this is known as back then the blunt
vaccine responses but it was not we
never had a novel antigen people get an
ass as adults you've had you've seen flu
before you've seen RSV before you see
you know and so we knew blunt did but we
didn't know how zero
um but you know we're probably at higher
risk of severe covid-19 but by February
21 it was clear that it was not a lot
higher you know factor of two to four
um thankfully not a factor of 30 for if
you get infected you're gonna end up in
a hospital you're dead
um
but the decision I have to make is undue
for my next treatment which is going to
deplete my B cells again and February
2021 vaccines are here but I don't yet
know when I'll be eligible
um of course the standard of care is the
neurologists think about neurology and
the you know Public Health people think
about covid and never the twain shall
meet
um they happen to intersect in my body
um professionally I'm up to date
um I will have no data like there's no
one can tell me what the vaccine
Effectiveness for people like me will be
um so my choices right are I can change
my treatment
um I can try to get my B cells back at
elevated risk for my Ms
um which
will last you know if that damage will
some usually only partially recovers
um I can also vaccinate whether my B
cells are depleted or not and see what
happens because we don't necessarily we
don't know 100 what's going to happen
right so I have to break down the
problem right I don't have to study so
there's Immunology I'm going to go a
little faster now there's my Ms
progression you know so what can I
predict about the vaccine what can I
predict about the interaction of vaccine
and my medicine what can I predict of if
I change my medicine what happens to my
Ms
um the key thing for decision making
under uncertainty is what do I value
what am I more afraid of what will I
feel stupider about if it goes wrong
um these were things I had to ask
um and then of course my decisions again
um while I'm saying a lot doesn't exist
there was an amazing paper by some real
experts in Ms Immunology that they wrote
in 2020 describing like based on what we
understand about the immune system this
is probably how this will work
um it was very helpful for covering not
the emotional parts of these issues not
the values driven parts of these issues
but the um the scientific parts and
largely got it all correct before we had
even vaccines
um so if you want to read one on this
topic go look up the baker 2020 paper on
uh covet vaccine Readiness
um so yeah we have data I'm going to
skip through this for time
um get to the last Point
um the data helped me make some
information I can calculate stuff about
Ms risk I can calculate stuff about
covert risk I'm in the position of
living in a place where we have good
estimates of covet prevalence because my
team is making them
um but it comes down to I the decision I
decide may my fears are you know so is
Ms going to put me in the hospital or is
covered going to put me in the hospital
giveaway I know of my exposure and the
data on litter trim both diseases
you know uncertainty is huge these are
calculations of multiplied relative
risks
um would you believe they came out
within a factor of two they were exactly
the same
um that meant if the decision was
entirely about what I valued hope for
and fear
um and that's actually I think why I
wanted to tell this story because
so much of decision making under
uncertainty is exactly about that
um and there's the interlude right
there's rarely an answer or rather
there's often no answer to the question
you wish was the right one to ask like I
wanted something to tell me you should
delay your vaccine and do your medicine
today or you should do your medicine
delay your medicine and do your vaccine
as soon as you can whatever
the answer could have came out that way
but it didn't right and that's the thing
like there are easy decisions in life
there are things where the outcomes are
totally dichotomous and by dichotomous I
mean the uncertainty is small relative
to the difference it's easy to know one
versus the other and pick
um this fell into the class of what I
might call a hard easy decision right so
the second type of is the MS one the
minor differences in outcomes it felt
like this decision mattered but given
the information either Choice was was
pretty much rational
um there's also a thing that I think a
lot of us got didn't do the way I would
have done during the pandemic um to that
effect you have you have a ton of
uncertainty but enormously asymmetric
outcomes these decisions should be easy
um the asymmetric outcome that can
happen dominates the risk
um these are places where the adjective
we feel under all that uncertainty is
often has a lot more to do with wanting
to be in control than actually needing
more information you know there are
actually hard decisions too you know you
don't have you have an important
decisions outcomes are meaningfully
different and you don't have the
evidence there are things called wicked
problems which is a great article
Wikipedia look up that term
um it's about things where there is the
answer to the question how do you ask
the question changes the answer the
answer changes the next question people
disagree on values and also just
personally overcoming your strong
beliefs
um a lot of coveted disagreement was
about these things which are not data
disagreements these are values
disagreements it's only this one that's
actually a science problem
um and understanding those
um is important so yeah and so one of
the things that we often took away for
our own work and for sharing with our
policy Partners is you know can we if
you have a decision you can't make
can you figure out a different way to
ask the question or a different way to
approach how you might do something that
would help the world change so that you
could answer the question you're trying
to avoid hard questions is an important
art
um so I will tell you with the last
minute or two that I want to take here
before I open up the questions
um you know the decisions I made I had
three rounds of this so I decided I
didn't know when vaccine was coming so I
went with standard of care I got my MS
treatment
um I got standard of care
um after knowing that my vaccine didn't
work very well I got no antibody
response um the next round I delayed
treatment
um I took advantage of lack's record
keeping to start over even though that
wasn't the policy it should be the
policy but it wasn't
um in my opinion it should be the policy
and so I got better than standard of
care for what I value I got a maximum
possible vaccine response in my Ms held
study
um interestingly I developed the Mild
Eczema which is an autoimmune reaction
something to think about
um
did the same thing again delayed updated
um you know covet exposure risk had
changed a lot Omicron changed things a
lot
um you know I don't I got a mad outcome
um I got the best vaccine response but I
had a bit of an MS relapse that's only
80 recovered it's not severe but that
last 20 is probably going to stay with
me the rest of my life and you know by
this point in time I had known how to
control my exposure pretty well and I
don't have kids yet
um and so I you know and so I don't know
that was the right choice
um I'm Gonna Save the reflections I will
leave a question for you of was it
ethical for me a wealthy white person
um working for a global Health
philanthropy that's had an a complex
place in the global vaccine effort uh
Global vaccine Equity landscape
um to take advantage of LAX record
keeping and get some extra doses I have
my answer to that
um I think it's a question you guys
might enjoy thinking about
um you know kind of to get to the point
here is this was my personal story that
lives in a very unique place in my
personal skill set
um but there are millions of people with
this kind of situation autoimmune
diseases in particular
um personalized medicine we often talk
about genomics
um this is about risk factor relative
risk for which much of the data that you
need to make these kind of decisions is
actually created by the scientific
process
um I would love to see someone some
whether it be you know a large
institution or academic program or
Pharma to take on the challenge of not
just a drug development but a drug a a
decision-making system development
because there is a approach to
randomized clinical trials of the
treatment process that could help people
with doctors say what do you value when
you have these competing risks here's
what we know about the competing risks
and the weights that we would apply to
them given your values
here's this here's how you think you can
make a decision
um and I bet you we figured out how we
could do that within better than
standard of care both in terms of lower
clinical morbidity and improve patient
satisfaction
um I think this is a really fruitful
area for the next 30 years of biomedical
data science that is only just beginning
to be poked out in a quantitative way
so to wrap up you know I'll leave you
here what do I hope to leave you with
right you know much of the story was
about the intersection between different
kinds of science that we do on the
regular right and as data scientists we
often try to say here's the data I have
here's the question what's the answer
within my data
um that's alone is bad often that
doesn't give you the right kind of
answer
um you know we descend from the natural
philosophers right it's often tempting
to think on you know here's how I think
the world Works what evidence supports
my model
um that alone is bad
um similarly as human animals right we
often say here's what I think and this
is what we should do
those are often prostitutes for actually
I'm avoiding what I feel and
I want us to do this thing I hope will
make me feel differently
um my so my Ms decisions will like that
and I think that's very worthy of love
and compassion but if you've motivated
if your motivation really this is about
feelings is why you're so certain is
obscure
um that's not a sound basis for Action
yet as scientists as as individuals
maintaining a dynamic balance on top of
all of these and other cells That's
essential to doing our job to the best
of our ability and I don't think we talk
about it enough and that's why I took a
chance to do this today so thank you
Mike thank you so much you know as you
were talking I was just thinking about
some of those early news reports that
were you know coming out on the national
news where it just looked like Seattle
was on fire with covet in those early
days and it this was so worrying and as
we were talking about before we got
started I have family there and in
Seattle and so it was like it must have
been absolutely frightening on the one
hand because you're there at you know in
The Hot Zone as it were you're seeing it
happen in real time you have a
responsibility as a scientist to be
taking these data and to be you know
turning them into something that's
actionable at the same time you're a
person with a particular Health concern
and you must have been absolutely
terrified and I was wondering how in
that position you were able to kind of
get that dispassionate kind of distance
between maybe where you're you know your
personal concern to basically put the
focus on the task at hand and to you
know Marshal that you know internal
fortitude to be able to go and do your
job how did you manage to do that
because that must have been scary as
heck thank you for asking that question
I almost started crying when you asked
it um the the fully honest and short
answer
um
I guess there's two there's kind of two
parts to it one is uh something I
started unpacking in therapy starting in
April 2020 is you know I had a you know
my family growing up had stuff that I
didn't fully understand that seemed
normal
um that worked together such that I'm
one of those people that gets calm when
things get stressful
um I I someone who's over it was over
trained to try to solve other people's
problems and figure out what is is going
on and how I can help
um and so there was a sense as as like
the enormous pressure was Building
inside of me um I was probably too good
to be honest at suppressing everything
um but then the other thing that
happened is like you know something I
still reflect on is like you know in
February 24th we hadn't started doing
using the covet tests on the you know
hundreds of respiratory samples a day we
were collecting with the flu study but
you know we were I was you know 99 sure
covet was somewhere circulating in the
United States
you know the next night you know we run
the first batch of tests and one out of
400 on the you know our positive
the difference between 99 sore and 100
sure felt way bigger than I ever thought
it would
and the next three weeks
um
we're the most Lucid of My Life
all sorts of things I mean like because
everything was the most important thing
it was actually really clear and my mind
was really quiet and it was weird stuff
like my mother-in-law um is a February
29th birthday and my knowledge of the
local epidemic started on February 26th
or 27th I remember correctly um but the
public knowledge hadn't yet
um and we had planned and as a February
29th birthday it was her 19th leap year
birthday as a 76 year old
um and there was a large dinner plan at
a restaurant
and I remember thinking
I the prevalence in this area is less
than one in a thousand and there will
not be a thousand people at this
restaurant we're not going to cancel
this dinner
um knowing that next week we were going
to never go to a restaurant again
um you know and and knowing that in
February when nobody else did
um but why bring that up is is it was
really easy to like be present at that
dinner because that was the most
important thing for that five hours
um and later that night we got calls
from a New York Times Reporter which I'd
never talked to before because Trevor
Bedford had tweeted out what we thought
was happening
um and that was the easiest thing to do
because it was it was scary but it was
like my father-in-laws and that worked
for three weeks and as soon as the team
around me really spun up and we had 30
people working together in the state
that's probably the public health
relationships
and the pressure came off a little bit
um I had to move the relax I
psychologically tore myself apart I was
a mess I was impossible with
um is like the foot was on the gas but
the load had eased off and the engine
was ripping itself apart and so that's
that's the honest answer
it's uh it's an incredible Story one of
the things that um one of our uh
listeners was is curious about about you
know now we're kind of on the the
downslope of covid and the emergency
declarations are ending at the state and
federal levels and it's a lot of people
who are in positions as modelers or data
scientists working in this space are
either losing interest in this area
because it's not you know hot air not
the hot area anymore
um or they're basically they're you know
being made redundant because of the jobs
going away what do you think are some of
the best uses of the modeling time and
resources uh during this what they
referred to as a relative peace time
yeah that's a great question it's one
that we're struggling with um where we
our effort at IDM is is down to skeleton
crew and and honestly mine is down to
almost zero
um
the way that I'm thinking about this
long term is there are lots of different
challenges
um
I putting the effort into
building relationships with people who
make
decisions
um building relationships with your
public health colleagues that are on the
things that they are actively caring
about being flexible about your disease
expertise
um but being you know fairly being
committed to your partnership and
decision making or modeling Niche
expertise are the places that I want us
to see us grow as a field because that's
what will be sustainable and that's also
what positions you to be reactive
effectively
um we were able to be of reactive
effectively because my Institute was
focused on working in Partnership across
Global Health we had a lot of experience
um
how and so I how you figure out how to
write that into funding proposals while
not losing the scientific knowledge
that's required to Pivot is a challenge
I don't think we've I don't think I know
how to tell you how to solve but it's
really it's it's putting Partnerships
ahead of viruses is I think the more
sustainable pathway here
right well Mike I want to thank you so
much for sharing your experience with us
um really at just the front lines of the
covid-19 pandemic in our country kind of
watching it happen in real time in those
early days and uh you know kind of
developing some of these models which
really spearheaded a lot of interest in
doing this
um at this kind of scale
um being in that position doing making
models with limited information and then
trying to improve upon them uh must have
been a very exciting but fraught and
emotional time for you personally and I
want to thank you for sharing your story
with us um it's really inspirational so
thank you thank you very much and thank
you everyone for for listening I hope uh
you know stuff you can take away from it
to reflect on for yourselves and I
appreciate that to share thank you thank
you Mike and everyone have a wonderful
weekend and we'll see you next week
bye-bye now bye